hello hey man it's Charlie oh hey
Charlie what's up well I'm actually only
really calling you because I wanted to
try out my new phone okay well what war
phone did you get it's a a handy phone I
don't know if you've I heard of it uh oh
yeah no totally man I've seen the
adverts and everything oh yeah yeah and
be phone it's an but it's a phone as
well yeah yeah it's pretty catchy so how
are you coping with the side effects man
I mean this is pretty big quick well you
the side effects will be seriously you
don't know no I mean I wasn't told
anything when I bought it or to get the
operation you know there's no going back
I mean your hands gonna be stuck like
that for the rest of your life so if you
can take in the piece no man I'm serious
I mean there was a guy on the news about
a week ago it's completely messed up his
life you can't you can't eat properly
'he's he's lost his job
you can't play computer games anymore
what man I'm so sorry
no no it's okay man dude if there's if
there's anything I can do no no no don't
worry about it
look I got some stuff to do anyway I'm
I'll speak to you later okay man sweetie
you soon bye
hello hey it's me
Luigi oh oh hey Luigi what's up look
Charlie just sent me a text message he
told me about the handy phone oh well we
you know I listen Charlie right I'm
gonna be honest with you I think it's
surf you kiddin right what all these
years I've known you and you've always
had to have the new gadget then you
think that everyone's been talking about
and you have never been able to respect
the classic call come on man that's not
fair it's true Charlie and you know it's
true but Charlie I'm breaking up with
you right don't try and call me I don't
have time for you anymore
I'm sorry Louise
and bone and bone it's a hair but it's a
bone as well
Surf's Up Charlie I'm breaking up with
you right don't try and cool me I don't
have time for you anymore I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry